[Applause]
[Music]
all right
[Music]
it's friday everyone and our last show
in nashville then
i know
then it's back to new york city
i wish i could express how i feel about
that
please don't let them take me can i just
stay a little longer i'll sleep on your
couch
i'll just
sleep on the couch i won't take up a lot
of room i sound like cat arguing with
her husband
but tonight we're going out with a bang
look who's here tonight
yes it's miss dana perrino
so glad uh
really happy she made it here here she
is arriving in nashville
[Music]
[Applause]
such a queen
but with both of us here i wonder what
the five was like today
now they're already in bed
yeah he does finally shaved by the way
perino is italian for the only person
smaller than gutfeld
as you can see cats here raved are that
good to see uh
good to see you uh made it to the to the
studio given last night's antics
[Music]
[Applause]
you know she may be clumsy but her
opinions are as clear as the terror in
her husband's eyes
so before we get to the monologue it's
time for
[Music]
greg seven jokes
[Music]
number one shocking news from the set of
the view host anna navarro and sunny
hostin tested positive for kovid
even worse the view tested positive for
joy behar
it's incurable they still had to rush
kamala harris uh far away from the
studio it was pretty easy they just told
her it was the southern border
[Applause]
[Music]
dog dog the bounty hunter has joined the
search for fugitive brian laundry police
consider his help crucial as they
believe laundry may be hiding inside a
mullet
good news a new york post headline
reports mcdonald's mcrib is mcback
the bad news is so is my mick diarrhea
to new research scientists say three
masks protect you the most
well i can't wait to hear the results of
their condom study
same principle
amazon unveiled the new household robot
for 999 bucks but if i'm paying a grand
for a robot made i'd better be able to
have sex with it
they'll call it the schwarzenegger
wow
and number seven u.s airlines are now
considering weight limits for passengers
in other news brian stelter i hope you
like trains
and that's greg's seven jokes
all right
back to the screaming hellscape called
manhattan did you hear as kids get shot
junkies take over and the elderly get
mugged by gangs of thugs also known as
democrats
the mayor has redefined policing as
customer service
literally the question from the nypd to
the people they serve how did we do
fundamental customer service idea
it's never existed previously in the
nypd but it's going to be the future of
the nypd even the very fact that we're
talking about customer service in the
context of nypd that's revolutionary
that's revolutionary
it is
i'm still wondering how did a festering
lincoln log become mayor
what is it with democrat leaders once
they win do they take a secret oath to
destroy everything
you couldn't ruin a big city faster if
you were mothra
de blasio has turned a once great city
into a cesspool of chaos which is a lot
like geraldo's hot tub
and like uh
[Applause]
and like geraldo's hot tub nyc is filled
with half-naked crazy people and it's
prone to flooding
so the police is now customer service
that's great it's no longer to protect
and serve it's let me help you return
that defective garden hose to home depot
at least after you get mugged you can
stay on the line and update your car
warranty
meanwhile the mugger's already been
released and on to his next victim while
you're on hold listening to air supply
so as crime explodes the mayor wants
community guides community guides to
greet visitors at city police stations
this is because he heard that the police
were gruff and dismisses dismissive well
mayor so are the muggers and the rapists
hell you just described everybody who
lives in new york the only new yorkers
who aren't
gruff are dead
thank you andrew cuomo
gruffness that's the problem here not
murder or assault so now we've turned
cops into walmart greeters that's the
problem with cities run by leftists they
conflate law and order with brutality so
the solution is emasculation worse we're
not even calling crime
crime anymore see this isn't crime it's
reallocations of goods
oh
look at this
insane
insane yo
yo this is the middle of the holster
right now
he has a future as a crime reporter
but you know the good news is if you
play that video in reverse it actually
looks like these guys work there and are
stalking the shelves
look at this
wow
insane
insane yo
yo this is the middle of the holster
right now
problem solved
and if we only had the police there to
greet them and help them load the stuff
into the stolen truck
yo sarge mind grabbing the end of this
flat screen
meanwhile as we excuse the criminals who
are the real threats parents the
national school boards association which
represents over 90 000 school officials
begged joe biden on wednesday to protect
them from angry mobs of parents upset
over vaccine and mass mandates that are
forced upon their kids saying the
parents should be treated as domestic
terrorism by extremist eight
organizations
yep to these buffoons a 28 year old
single mom looking out for her kids is
the same as a one-eyed monster with a
hook for a hand
so they implored biden to mobilize the
fbi in secret service to guard school
officials the sad part is he'll probably
listen
the teachers unions realize that the
worst thing about kovid is parents
realizing how bad the teachers unions
are and now that parents are taking a
more active role in protecting their
kids from these idiots they're now
considered a threat but these days
anyone who disagrees with these craven
self-righteous sanctimonious a-holes can
be considered a threat remember the
soldier who spoke up about the
afghanistan debacle he's still in the
brig and how about that u.s marine who
rescued a baby in kabul during that
botched withdrawal he's allegedly under
investigation after he was invited up
onto a stage by donald trump last week
i am the guy that uh pulled the baby
over the wall and it's definitely
probably one of the greatest things i've
ever done in my entire life
well not so fast buster hopping up on
that stage might have violated policy
even though he was invited on the stage
by a former president still they treat
him like he's john hinckley it's like
the biden administration is attempting
the biggest purge
since tyrus went on that juice cleanse
so you see what's happening here we are
criminalizing citizens and
decriminalizing crime it makes no sense
but maybe it's the only way democrats
can lower crime statistics the jerks
she's the nicest host at fox news and if
you disagree she'll stab you in the face
america's newsroom co-anchor and the
five ghost data burrito
and there's nothing wrong with your
screen that's just how he looks ryder
comedian joe devito
she's like an armadillo a tough exterior
but prone to curling up in a ball [ __ ]
his contributor
and finally his watch band is your
waistband my massive sidekick and the
nwa world television champion
tyrus dana welcome to nashville i know
that you've you've never really been
down south before
quite an exciting uh experience you've
been arrested numerous times for
horrific crimes this must be a relief
that the cops will not be greeting more
and cuffing less it'll be great you know
i was thinking when they said that uh
they were gruff and dismissive yes i've
lived in new york ten years i've even
become gruff
and dismissive over that time no not
really i'm not um i was thinking though
this might be good news for those
business owners that have homeless
people sitting outside their shops for
years on end there's this one girl she
has been sitting outside the juice
generation
for like i don't know eight years right
and she's pregnant wow for eight years
she's begging for two
yeah so i think that if you have
customer service right now that maybe
that maybe now the business owners can
be helped along oh my god so maybe
you're saying that this could be a good
idea and that and i might be wrong
i didn't see it like that why how did
you see it i saw it like they were
implying that there's people that would
talk to the cops but worried that
they're rude
like there's i would snitch on my mob
boss but i heard the cops don't say
please and thank you
and also again it's like that liberal
thing where they they sniff around the
edges of a huge problem and then they
say problem is solved by solving
something that didn't need solving i
don't want a non-gruff cop cat no i i
think you're supposed to be gruff when
you fight crime yeah it'd always be
weird and passive aggressive if you
weren't yes
was it the crime-fighting dog mcgruff
yeah he didn't smile no he didn't smile
at all
why would you when you know you're going
to be dead in 14 years oh
probably not a good joke joe
joe tibito thank you dead dead dog to me
thank you yes yes well it reminds me of
your beard
uh i wish you could show that clip of de
blasio backwards so the go into his
mouth
it's so the idea that the police are
supposed to do customer service how how
exactly does that work with your your
fifth assault conviction you get a free
ice cream sundae is that how they're
gonna do it
it's it's amazing what he's done to new
york city it's like in the movies where
you see the character throw the match
over his shoulder and everything
explodes behind him that's bill de
blasio every day when he leaves the
house he's destroying new york city in
some new and exciting way that's like me
when i when i leave a restroom
please don't use a match yeah i i i risk
the world when i light a match
probably shouldn't have said that out
loud probably should have thought about
it and then gone to tyrus
and said hi tyrus hi greg love the hats
funny joke greg yes
you got the boots in that excuse me
while i whip this out
[Laughter]
always wanted to say that
you know
i'm i'm kind of mad about this because
in my youth when i was a knucklehead
it'd have been nice i'm like freeze get
on the ground i'd like to speak to a
manager yeah
in the comments oh sorry sir we'll be
right back you know more time to get
away we've just lost our mind
customer service
protecting you from criminals is
customer service yes
kicking in the door and saving you is
customer service yeah if anyone needs
customer service it's our men and women
in blue that need customer service from
politicians
and i would just like to say
to the family of snakes that gave all
they could
thank you
that's snakeskin
it was yes it's my skin now
and one last point because we didn't
really talk about how the teachers group
are calling parents
uh potential terrorists we are now we
are now entered the stage where we're
weaponizing the potential threat have
you noticed this now everybody anybody
can be a potential threat i'm a
potential threat for even pointing this
out it's now like ever since they did
this whole like there's this invisible
terrorist threat domestic threat now
anybody can be finger it can be fingered
and not in a good way oh god
well no i asked one to end on greg
look as
a parent this is a double-edged sword
they cry when we don't get involved in
our kid's school then when we get
involved how dare you question what i'm
going on you're a terrorist if you call
me out yeah
you're a terrorist if you don't agree
with me you're a terrorist if you hold
me accountable well just i'll change
this what what's the new hat terrorists
wear these days get me one they want to
use the patriot act yeah to go after
united states citizens i mean
how do you think this ends that doesn't
end well right but this segment ended
well
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else